okay this is uh the first time that i've
had uh
both of these ladies on the show
together uh
they were both in studio uh separately
but now they're part of a
terrific talk show together on vice vice
tvs carrie and jamelle won't stick to
sports
uh 11 30 p.m on thursday nights jamelle
hill and carrie champion here on the
show how are you ladies good to see you
good thank you for having us we
appreciate it yes definitely
i'd say this is the coolest sports
center anchor reunion i've been part of
in quite some time
i i agree i agree i even i didn't even
register right away
i got to tell you working with jamel has
been a breath of fresh air we
we often look at each other and say i
can't believe they're paying us to do
this
but that's good nevertheless there it is
the direct deposit to prove that it
actually happens
but i feel very comfortable in saying of
the three of us
i had the shortest tenure on
sportscenter so
now come on now but you you you know you
you were
both of you were on during the day or
you in the early evening jemele i i had
uh many a moon where i would look at
stuart scott and we would look at the
watch and we go really is that really is
it 3
15 in the morning like literally that's
my if i had to peg my
out time on sportscenter like whenever
we didn't punch a clock obviously but
it would be somewhere around three in
the morning that's literally when i did
my job so you're better you're better
than us
because i would have been in bed by then
it was a it was i actually the noon
shift for me was great i know jemele you
like the six as well but the noon was
great i had my whole day
afterwards it was it's interesting
because rich you were a part of
a um just the legacy of what
sportscenter was you built it you stu
um they were so dan um keith there were
so many
um people there just legends and then
when we came on there was a new version
definitely when jay came on it was a new
version of sportscenter but
it was it was a it was a new version of
sportscenter and i always
felt like you know the powers that be
were trying to
live the years that you all had created
you know what i mean they were trying to
recreate that without moving ahead
well it's nice carrie but i'll be honest
with you when stewart and i were doing
it and i think i've had conversations
with both of you separately on this very
subject
but when stuart and i were doing
sportscenter together we you know and
it's nice of you to say that we were
helping create it
you know uh we we didn't know if it was
working at the time to be honest with
you
you know we we were like i think this is
working and
um i was sitting there you know somewhat
concerned about whether it was working
and stuart didn't care you know
honestly he was like i think it's
working and i know what i'm doing is
gonna work and i'm gonna keep doing it
like literally that's the way it felt
when we were
when we were doing sportscenter together
well it's funny the more
as you talk to more sportscenter alums
and certainly i bet
on some level the people who are
currently doing sports that would say
this is that
we all have some version of the same
story or our side
support center of um you know going
through that
sometimes volatile and tumultuous phase
where you're trying to do something
different or put your own
stamp on sportscenter and it's not
necessarily appreciated by everybody
and how daily you know you wind up in
in uh fights and um you know just kind
of fighting
not necessarily for your survival but
fighting for your peace of mind
like on a single on a daily basis and i
i think i said this to carrie when we
were when we started doing the the vice
show or as we got deeper into it
is i think about the show that we we do
now on vice and
i think about um what i was doing at
espn and i honestly don't know how i did
it every day
i was like i can't believe i used to do
this five days a week this is crazy
human beings were not built for this
yeah you know so sportscenter itself is
much different but you
but you grew up different jay grew up
paper right
so for us tv kids who start off in the
small markets and one man bands
like that that to me makes sense like
that was you did
of course that's just what you did you
didn't have a choice and even started on
first take that was just two hours of tv
and you just sit you know what i mean
every day and so you felt like that's
just what it was
i think what's interesting is that this
this new version of what it was
sportscenter had a hard time dealing
with how social media told the news
before
you know they wanted to live with the
highlights i'm like we already saw that
so you always have to be able to tell
somebody something different outside of
the highlight what's the other new
element to it
this is news not old and so i think for
me when i came on that was the real
tough transition because
everything is available now streaming
online like if you're not in the
streaming online game
you're not in the game you know what i
mean in terms of sports you're just not
because they want it immediate and they
want it quickly
no doubt i mean literally you and i but
jemele hill and carrie champion here
on the rich eisen show you and i are
talking on a zoom
to be recorded to be put on a stream you
know like that's literally
but that's literally what we're doing
now right and
and it's interesting that you said when
you said carrie because i was i remember
when you know um when 911 hit and we
were on sportscenter and the bottom line
that cnn used that scrawl to put all of
the
you know to put all of the headlines on
there um
sportscenter decided to to use it and so
here i am on sportscenter delivering a a
lead-in
setting up to the highlight and the
final score
appeared on the bottom line right across
my chest and i'm like
well that sucks like
[Laughter]
what are we doing and yeah like it
turned the news into old you know
to use your phrase right there i was
literally the only sports center anchor
who complained about it and they're like
you know
whatever and then i i'll be honest with
you i just
didn't want to continue doing a sports
center where it was about the why what
happened
as opposed to the what happened like
you're saying like to give
it added perspective as to what's going
on because
the way that would be set up would be we
had to have one analyst who took
one point of view and another analyst
and took the other point of view and
bashed them together
and it's just something i just didn't
want to i just wasn't into it that much
anymore to be honest with you but
i'll be honest i would have stayed like
if if things were set up in a certain
way
but um it changed there's no question
about it
it changed yeah when we're there
we both we both jamal and i are quiet
you would have stayed
honest okay i i i'm i'm being very
honest with you here uh like uh there
were certain parts of of the
the toy chest i wanted to play you know
in you know with the expanding world
it didn't work out you know and um but
things
things just um it's just a show i just
didn't want to do much anymore
to be ready you know here's what's in
it's interesting richard you say that
and i respect you for saying that
because
again i i know you don't think so but
it was creative for people who wanted to
just talk sports 24 hours a day what's
going on
evaluate it break it down do it find it
every which way every
every person we can interview everything
however what has happened
um which is uh really truly how our show
came about is that
there are parts of sports that you can
no longer ignore if you're a journalist
you cannot your spirit doesn't sit right
for me uh
there was a time i guess like from not
you know 2016 to 2018 where we were
covering
you know everything you know on and off
the court on and off the field because
they did coexist it coexisted in how
these athletes of their lives and how
people respected them or didn't respect
them
namely colin kaepernick and when we
started to veer away from that as so
many people want you to do
um as a journalist just that it's at the
core of what we do i felt like we
weren't asking the really honest
questions or telling the true story or
all of the story and that
is when i got uncomfortable that's when
i felt like i was flipping burgers
that's why i was like okay i'm not you
know what i mean i'm not doing what i
love and part of what i love is yes
sports but it's also a part to tell the
whole story
well i mean i think yeah since you know
i don't mean to
interrupt you right there and that i
guess that's what
you know what's so intriguing about your
current show who came up with the title
where let's just hit the nail right on
the head
like let's just title the show right on
the head
that you won't stick to sports like who
how did that one
come about well it
was funny because like we we went
through a couple titles
in fact the initial press release is a
completely different title that has
nothing to do with what you see
and as we started to workshop some names
um the intention was to have a
um stick to sports segment that is what
was supposed to be initially worked into
the show
but the more um you know we batted it
around the more
the powers that be the decision makers
they did too and really liked the title
and uh for us it became a rallying cry
because
both of us um while espn and certainly
since we've left there
went through a period where we were
receiving a lot of criticism
because we did not want to stick to
sports and like harry said
people have to remember like we're
career journalists that
if there are other things that are
colliding with sports
and and you know to some degree not to
some but people were being so
intellectually lazy about the stick to
sports thing like neither one of us were
ever on sportscenter
breaking down immigration law we never
did that like we weren't breaking down
healthcare reform you know what i'm
saying like we weren't out there talking
about tax codes like
no it was never like that we were
talking about the messy intersections
between sports race politics culture
gender which are apparent and all around
us right that's part of the story of
sports
and i just got really tired and i know
kerry did too it was just mentally
exhausting
to argue with people about whether or
not we should be discussing very
relevant
issues um in sports because there were
some people who were
uncomfortable it's funny when we have
other messy
intersections mostly things that don't
have to do with gender or race
people are fine with those right like if
we um you know i know it's a different
type of of issue that has obviously
touched a lot of people
um but nobody tells anybody to stick to
sports if we're talking about
cancer or certain diseases or like
nobody ever says a thing right
but then remember i always say this i
hate to interrupt if colin kaepernick
was kneeling for cancer he'd be
an american hero if he said i'm kneeling
for cancer or would you name another
another
issue i mean you know that
could be to be honest the other part of
that is if colin kaepernick had hit a
woman he'd be playing in the nfl
right or been accused of hitting a woman
he'd be in the nfl
because that is a corrective behavior
that they feel like they can fix
they can get you to stop doing that
right they can't get you to stop
believing police brutality and racism
and systemic oppression
exists that that tube is out of the
toothpaste so
i got tired of dealing with a
intellectually dishonest element
um both in the building at espn and
outside of it
that said that we shouldn't touch what
is
so plain and obvious in everybody's face
and it's like if you lose the ability to
tell the truth as a journalist then why
are you a journalist
then it doesn't really make any sense so
um you know from that standpoint
i think us choosing to title stick to
sports was about
giving a middle finger to the people who
kept telling us that
your mel hill and i'm sorry i'm i'm
resetting here
uh for the radio audience that we'll be
watching gary champion and jamel hill
here on the rich on joe go ahead carrie
i mean interrupt you
no i didn't mean interrupt you either i
laugh at jamal because this is such a
it's so interesting the world we live in
um we can't both can be true i can be a
journalist and
live to tell you highlights and tell you
about you know the game last week and
while i really was disappointed to see
pat my homes go out
because i really wanted to see more of a
fight i can get i can do that but then i
can also tell you
um about something else that's happening
um in the world of sports and that's
that messy intersection i don't
i don't remember when we weren't allowed
to do both
i i often think of the very first show i
started on which is first take they were
allowed to do it and i think for espn as
long as you have one show addressing it
it's on the menu
and the other shows can't address it and
i understand that too
i understand that philosophy because at
the end of the day it's business right
that's the bottom line like ratings
business make money
right and i'm okay with all of those
things
i for me you know very much different
than my colleague who will tweet every
five seconds and let everybody have it
for me
i i just wanted to make sure that i was
committing a couple of acts of
journalism a show
right i just wanted to communicate a few
acts of journalism and
and i would have been fine with that i
think that the problem is is that we
tried to hide now
now though you see rich even if you
watch times have changed they have
political guests on there all the time i
turn around somebody's talking politics
and i'm like wait hold on that wasn't
allowed when we oh i i know that and
but it's it's not just espn obviously
here too like
there there are uh many sports outlets
now
that have um you know one would say if
we're in a country
where we're talking about right and left
that have the right
uh conservative point of view talking to
the you know um the i guess
by the time this airs um afternoon on
the former president of the united
states um you know
so trump's been on bar stool trump's
been on
outkick you know i mean and so
that's just for me a sign that
stick to sports is dead i mean the
number of sports athletes that came out
and
said for biden or trump um i lost track
on both sides
and uh it's dead it's totally dead
but there is a line here where people
want to tune in
to watch sports and they're like well i
don't want to get sports with politics
well
guess what like when and the nba is
talking about
stopping play this is part of
sports that this is something that needs
to be discussed if this is on the on the
minds of athletes
this is something that needs to be
discussed and as you said jamel you
didn't lead sportscenter talking about
it wasn't policy center you know
maybe because they couldn't find a
sponsor but you know
you know you know what i'm saying like
so i do
the budweiser hot seat
that'll be something you know
i mean definitely the national security
council is definitely a hot seat
well long story short is that there
there is a way that i think that that
this can be
discussed and and not denigrated
as as ruining somebody's sports
experience because you know we also have
to be
clear though rich about when people say
stick to sports
we also have to be honest about what
they really mean
they don't want everybody to stick to
sports i only want
some people as in black people to stick
to sports i mean generally speaking is
that
you know like with um with one of the
complaints that we hear
is that you know it's when certain
athletes say something and about certain
issues you know we're talking about
very thorny emotional issues in this
country
racism police brutality these are not
easy subjects and so
a lot of the times um that would be the
case because
i'm guessing you know you mentioned you
know barstool and
and out kick um doing the trump
interview i didn't hear a whole lot of
complaints about them sticking to sports
because of who they are and who they
were interviewing no i understand
i i get it a lot you know i i i spoke
over the summer
um you know when jacob blake was
murdered i spoke out over the summer
when george floyd was murdered i mean
i i i had the you know a platform
and i felt it was necessary for me to
use it not only because i
felt it and i believed it but i want my
children to
you know when they go on youtube when
they're old enough to see
if they ever wonder what a dad have to
say about us when the world was falling
apart
that they can actually see that i i did
something and i spoke about it
but you know um you know that was about
the who though rich that was about the
hoop because
you were speaking up you know as a white
man
on behalf of black people so you you
don't catch these strays as well
okay
i think they come over all i agree with
you jamal in terms of yeah it probably
is more about the issues of people
speaking about the black community but i
think people in general who don't want
to hear about sports
and don't want to hear about it period
they don't care what brett favre thinks
they don't care
who you know i really truly believe all
around there
there's an overall fatigue from people
who just want to sit
and listen and watch sports the problem
is
that's not the world we live in we're in
a pandemic if we can't talk about the
messy issues and the
the repercussions and the domino effect
of a pandemic and what has happened
and what has left our country in the
state that it's in
it it touches everything i feel like
it's just really
um you know it's so uh
ridiculous to think that these athletes
who are playing risking their lives on
the collegiate level
on the professional level um won't
feel what is happening won't feel that
mental
lockdown i was talking to a player the
other day for the golden state warriors
he told me he was depressed
he was like playing in this pandemic is
depressing now
do we talk about that is that something
is that stick to sports are we allowed
to talk about
how depressed some of these athletes are
because of what they're dealing with but
yet they're out here entertaining us 24
hours a day seven days a week
no i'm uh absolutely mental health is
something that's that's uh
considerable and something we should
talk about do we you know before
i i let you ladies go do do you want to
talk sports
i mean yes let's talk to the board all
right well
then this is the topic i kind of want to
you know um toss to
uh in one here because the city of
houston
uh harden essentially either spoke uh or
ate
his departure into existence and now
he's in a
spectacular spot and i'm wondering if
deshawn watson
the front row seat of all this is
thinking the same exact thing
in a sport where usually somebody who's
got a nine-figure contract
can't speak something like that into
existence and i'm wondering
what you think of hardin's departure and
uh what's going on with watson
and how you think that might play out
you want to take that um
is it just me or does james harden
already look slimmer
i swear to god it feels like he looks
slimmer honestly like the jh-13 system
whatever that is
like if he can lose 30 pounds in like 48
hours
or maybe maybe it's the spite i don't
know what that is but
he looks slimmer maybe it's just being
in a black uniform
i don't know what it is but i i swear he
lost 10 pounds the moment he showed up
as a brooklyn net um look at we know in
the nba it's a players league
and despite the monstrosity of a
contract that james harden had
um at the end of the day somebody who
doesn't want to be there is not going to
do your franchise any good
but with football as you mentioned rich
the dynamics are different the players
don't really have a lot of leverage but
in this case if you're houston
what are your options desean watson is
in his mid-20s
he is a special talent he is an mvp
caliber quarterback which you know those
are difficult to find
all he asked through was to be consulted
right
he had in his mind he wanted eric the
enemy that was the guy that he felt like
could take this team to the levels that
they have not reached
it is the height of insulting that they
would not interview aaron beattoby who
by the way
regardless of the decide child watching
even said anything they should have been
interviewing anyway right
and the disrespectful nature i think of
what they did
sometimes and i'm not gonna say any
names but i've been in those work
situations before that once you show
them
once you get shown who they are it's
very hard to unreal what situation
what situation jacob i'm saying i've
been i've been in those situations
before
and sometimes when they show you
rich put on his glasses i don't have
time for this nonsense ladies and
gentlemen no
we're here to talk sports with you
it is hard i'm a 51 year old man carrie
come on
so if you're houston either you hire
aaron the enemy
or you lose deshaun watson and you have
to ask yourself
what's it worth it to you is it is he is
he the type of talent and i think that
he is
where it is worth it for you to make him
happy because you do not want to be
looking for
another one of those kind of
quarterbacks all over again
over something that was as simple
as consideration i think jay you're
right on with that but here's what's
even more interesting i think a little
if we go another level uh that
organization has made some questionable
decisions you know and we've watched
something else is going on there so i
don't think it was just this moment
in which desean said he's upset i think
it was a series of things that he
watched unfold and he thought well why
no why no consideration do you guys
really want to win is someone here to
help me
who really runs that team is it really
his team you would think it would be
i i don't know i don't think everything
that we see on the outside is what it
what it is and that's normally the case
but i agree with you he is
um as his his collegiate coach called
him he does have a michael jordan s
quality about him that i believe needs
to be
protected and loved and nurtured and i'm
taking my talent
to south beach if you're not taking care
of me i'm not saying he's going to miami
but you know go back to lebron
but i'm taking my talents elsewhere if i
can't be respected and he has the
leverage how many times
in your career rich how many times are
your careers your mail do you have
leverage
and when you do have leverage it's a
small window and and then you get the
best that you want
as far as james harden i'm not for sure
if i believe that will work out the
laker
fan in me is speaking but also the
journalist
and me is telling you those have been
like
talking this ain't the journalist
although although rich those
personalities talk to me about those
personalities do we see them all
coexisting
harmoniously well you're you're you're
you're you know and i guess to
just finish up this conversation here um
because i don't want to keep you where
we this has been a great conversation
but
there's a third man in and kyrie you
know and i guess i should
i should be like this when i have this
conversation
[Laughter]
this is how he showed up you know and
i'm kind of like what gives
like you know uh in the same way that
you're talking about how the texans need
to cherish something
or someone so generationally talented
and also
desean what beats in here not just as a
champion but as a human
is just such a rare combination
that you need to make sure that somebody
like that stays on your team
i mean what sort of situations won with
lebron and now
like i i don't know what it is
um going on with him but he's with
harden and he's with durant now and this
is
an incredible situation and and it's all
set up by the
the glory that the nba exists in a
pandemic we're so lucky that we get to
talk about it can't imagine
playing it can you suss out what is
going on between us i don't know him
i've never met him
i i just can't compute
anybody uh i did i did an event with
kyrie
um this past i think it was the summer
mondays and sundays feel the same so
just let's just say that last four to
six months i think it was sooner than
that
and it was an event um uh where
it was him and common and um we
were talking about um supporting black
women more and all the social justice
issues happening in the country
right kyrie's extremely thoughtful he's
very smart
um but he's also i think he's somebody
and i say this with no inside knowledge
kerry brought it up a minute ago
about players who are struggling a
little bit more playing under these
circumstances than we think that they
are
i think this is something that we're
seeing with him
because remember he didn't want to go to
the bubble he was ready to shut it down
he did not think the players should be
playing and i think that
these issues that have happened in our
country i'm not saying this is 100
the case but i do think that
on a deeper level seeing everything that
happened in this country in 2020
i would not be surprised if in having
you know some introspective
conversations with himself
if he wondered about what he was really
doing with his life
and about what he what his purpose was
i think he strikes me as somebody
looking for purpose and
i think he wondered is basketball my
purpose you know i mean he brought
the family of george floyd um a home um
he started a fun for wnba players
who decided to opt out um and playing in
the wubble
i mean he is doing so much on the social
and political realm
i'm one i i did wonder when he took that
little time out
is he thinking like is basketball really
where i want to be
right now again i say this with no
insider knowledge but this is the
impression
that i got from him after we did that
event together where he could not have
been more lovely but he's a thinker
he is a thinker yeah i was going to say
he's very mercurial and he stays in his
head a lot
and and you always what happens is we
forget we watch them we watch the
maturation process rich these kids come
in
they didn't socialize the way that we
probably think they should they didn't
have this experience and then we're
watching them grow into whomever they
think they are so here he is
you know i remember him just like when
they won the chip
when he was with the cavs and lebron
they won a chip and you know i see beer
bottles and
ladies and this that in the third now
he's you know taking sage and running it
around
you know you know the garden is so like
he's been all over like he's growing
you're right on and i
think he's just trying to figure it out
i think he's very expressive and we're
watching it happen and he's very
comfortable being expressive a lot of
people aren't that comfortable
you know what i mean they wait till they
retire to let you see who they are and
he's he's figuring that out and he's
like y'all y'all have to see this happen
as i'm watching it happen as well well
uh this has been awesome
everyone needs to watch these ladies go
at it um on
vice on thursday nights at 11 30 p.m
eastern time with carrie and jamelle
won't stick to sports
thanks for doing this we should do this
more often i honestly should
love it that's the surface you're saying
you were both very tough to pin down you
got a lot
no we would do it any time for you it's
so much fun we got to do it when we talk
about stu
because you know we all i got our
favorite stew stories we like to share
definitely and i just you know want to
describe for the radio audience i've got
my
library background it's a very nice
curtain you've got back there very nice
and carrie and uh with the emmy award
nice humble flag yes not really humble
i just want you to know back there in my
background for a reason because i want
you to ask me about it
hello and harry champion check them out
on vice tv on thursday nights at 11 30
p.m eastern time
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here